tis the season for resolutions you may
have given up yours already where are we
were january fifteenth it may be too
late to even speak to them but here we
are there's an icon in the upper right
corner of my imac screen that says
resolutions 2012 haven't even looked at
it for a week a little scared of it and
i'm not sure that's where the focus for
this weekend should be this season of
Epiphany this mark season of Martin
Luther King Day I think we are called to
a different kind of role than a self
improvement plan that inward-looking
guilt-inducing sense that I should be a
superhuman super moral super perfect
kind of person I think we're called to a
different kind of faith and I think
that's what our scriptures speak to
today st. John wrote the word became
flesh and dwelt among us full of grace
and truth that's the scripture we read
at Christmas every year but we're past
Christmas were into a new season and I
think sometimes the Word of God needs a
helper think sometimes the Word of God
needs a midwife or a messenger or a
middleman and I think that is our role
our scriptures today are about unlikely
unrecognized heroes those who at just
the right moment were the connection
between the Word of God and those who
are looking for God the middle Midwife
call it the middle man called the
messenger they usually aren't the heroes
of the story that's reserved for the
mother or the child for the buyer or the
seller for the sender or receiver the
Word of God the call of God goes out but
often it takes a midwife or a messenger
to put the call through in this church
in the season of Epiphany we celebrate
God's Word going out to the world and
for this season the messengers are
Rose our passage from First Samuel
begins the word of the Lord was rare in
those days visions were not widespread
sounds like today perhaps but we are in
11th century BC in Israel we are at the
sanctuary in Shiloh long before the
Jerusalem Temple and Eli the priest
presides over that sanctuary and the boy
Samuel dedicated by his mother Hannah
serves there but Eli is growing old the
priest and his sons have desecrated the
sanctuary sleeping with the women who
come to pray and stealing the food
dedicated to God the nation is troubled
by enemies and lost without a judge to
lead them it is a trouble time a time
when the Word of God is rare perhaps
like today no shortage of religion no
shortage of anti religion but the word
of the Lord the vision of the Lord is
rare when young Samuel comes to Eli late
at night saying Here I am you called me
Eli's not happy his sleep is already
troubled and here is this dreaming boy
but what happens a third time even Eli
Eli compromised already by his sons
losing his purpose even he remembers
what the word of the Lord sounds like
and he sends Samuel back to bed with the
instructions when you hear the call say
speak to Lord for your servant is
listening the result for Eli sadly is
not going to be a happy one Samuels
first vision is of God's destruction of
Eli's family but Eli still plays this
crucial role Eli is the Midwife he is
the middleman teaching Samuel how to
recognize the voice of God and receive
it in our gospel today st. John tells
the story of Jesus
arriving in Galilee calling his first
disciples to him along the way the very
beginning of the story we hear a story
of Philip and Nathaniel jesus meets
Philip coming into Galilee and tells him
follow me and Phillip does but Phillip
goes the next step and finds his friend
Nathaniel and he tells him we have found
the one spoken of in the law and the
prophets Jesus from Nazareth it's very
early in the Jesus story and they don't
really know who he is or what he's
teaching but they can see his power and
his love and they racked their brains
for titles from scripture to call and
there's the disciples are still trying
to find words for emotions about him
they don't understand the understanding
will come much much later after years of
teaching and healing after trial and
execution on an Easter morning but we're
back at the beginning and Phillip goes
to his friend with this mystery we have
found the one Moses spoke of he is Jesus
from Nazareth and Nathaniel rather
snarkily responds can anything good come
out of Nazareth imagine your best friend
coming to you and saying we have found
the leader the one who will save us and
he is Stanley from hoboken
that's what Jesus from Nazareth sounded
like to Nathaniel and so he laughs and
he snarkily says nothing good can come
from there but Philip is the needed
middleman he doesn't argue with
Nathaniel he doesn't get offended at his
snarky tone he just says okay come and
see Philip doesn't get theological or
political he doesn't try to entice
Nathaniel he says the words that
skeptical Nathaniel needs to hear trust
your own eyes come and see the Midwife
the middleman the messenger sees what
God is doing sees the need for God in
others and makes the connection the word
may come late at night to a boy a new
disciple needs just the right response
to call him forth to a life of purpose
the middleman is the one of whom Roman
says how beautiful are the feet of the
messenger that brings the good news
there's a wonderful story i read this
week by Reverend Cynthia Weems of First
United Methodist Church in Miami and
I'll quote from it because it's too good
not to hear her words she tells the
story of a middleman coming to her she's
in her first job as a minister in a big
Midwestern city she's in a urban church
since having tough times and she's just
started but she gets a request from a
friend to translate into Spanish for the
father of Victor an eleven-year-old boy
coming before the Youth Court because
he'd shot another child in the leg with
a BB gun at 11 year old she goes to
court she translates and Victor was
sentenced to 25 days community service
and Reverend Williams realized his
family lived just three blocks away from
her church and so she offered to let him
serve his community service there so he
came the next morning and he was given
the task of cleaning a dirty disused
youth room on the third floor and it was
told if he did it well he and his
friends could use it as a gathering
place so he worked hard
he took it seriously got the room in
order but his other community service
task was to help with Vacation Bible
School and Victor didn't like anything
with the word school in the title but he
came and he helped and he brought his
friends Fernando and Javier and Pedro
revin dreams rights that she didn't
really want to help Victor and his
family she didn't want to supervise
Victor for his project there were so
many other calls on her life she was a
new pastor visiting church families
denominational work all the tasks and
urban pastor has maintaining a building
in a changing neighborhood but during
the week of vacation bible school
Victor's friend Pedro came up to her at
one point and asked pastor you know
those community service hours that
Victor has how can I get some of those
she writes I was stunned to attention
all the other voices crying out for my
attention stopped and I was silent and I
listened the voice of the Lord was about
to speak it was clear and it came with a
challenge do kids have to shoot someone
with the BB gun before they're invited
to our church eleven-year-old Pedro
didn't know he was the messenger of god
but he was allowing the message to come
through loud and clear often the Bible
seems to be calling us to be superheroes
to be healers to be peacemakers to be
miracle workers but today's stories of
eli and Phillip and Pedro offer a
different kind of discipleship the
discipleship of making connections in my
preaching class last semester Tom kroger
and Nora Tisdale ask those second-year
prospective preachers to write a short
exercise for the end of the class just
one page in which they would write the
sermon they most wanted to hear them
selves and almost without fail these
theological scholars these leaders of
tomorrow's church these activists and
change agents wrote one very simple
message that they needed to hear God
loves you no matter what just that
simple profound never repeated too often
message God loves you no matter what yes
there's much more to say but what the
world longs is to hear that story of
God's love for me when I'm at my lost
and my lowest but you can not only hear
that message you can transmit it you can
be the message whereby those who are at
their lost or lowest point in life can
hear that message whether you're an
introvert or an extrovert I know because
you're here that you're someone who
loves people who watches people who
wanders about people and for you there
is a special calling to make that
connection between the word of the Lord
and the people who need to receive it
God is speaking but Samuel can't hear
unless you tell him how to listen
Nathaniel is too sarcastic to come to
see unless you invite him children are
waiting to be invited in but it takes a
child asking if he has to be punished
first or the church to welcome him to
wake us up you are the one who can make
the connection the need is too real the
emptiness in many of our hearts is so
resounding the fear the lack of
resilience the brittleness many of our
hearts is calling us help me hear what
God is saying
show me what God might do share with me
your experience I don't need for you to
give me the answers I don't need for you
to be a theologian I don't need for you
to be a moral exemplar even I just need
for you to tell me this is what worked
for me this is how I heard god this is
how I saw God this is what changed my
life come and see